en el que el color de nuestra piel no solo causa una primera impresión,
sino la definitiva.
Nací en una familia llena de colores.
Mi padre es hijo de una dama
de quien heredó un intenso tono chocolate oscuro.
Fue adoptado por quienes conozco como mis abuelos.
La matriarca, mi abuela,
tiene una piel de porcelana y cabellos de algodón.
Mi abuelo estaba entre un tono vainilla y el tono del yogur de fresa,
como mi tío y mi primo.
Mi madre es hija de una nativa de Brasil,
de piel canela con un toque de avellana y miel
y de un hombre con la piel café con leche,
pero con mucho café.
Ella tiene dos hermanas.
Una con una piel maní tostado
y la otra,
también adoptada,
está más bien tirando al beige,
como un panqueque.
(Risas)
Creciendo en esta familia,
el color nunca fue importante para mí,
pero al salir de la casa las cosas fueron cambiando rápidamente.
El color tenía muchos otros significados.
Recuerdo mis primeras clases de dibujo en la escuela
como un remolino de sentimientos encontrados.
Era divertido y creativo,
pero nunca entendí el único lápiz color carne.
Yo era de carne, pero no era rosa.
Mi piel era marrón y la gente decía que era negra.
Tenía siete años y un lío de colores en mi cabeza.
Luego,
cuando acompañaba a mi primo a la escuela,
la gente me confundía con la niñera.
Si ayudaba en la cocina en la fiesta de un amigo,
la gente pensaba que era la criada.
Fui incluso tratada como prostituta
solo porque estaba caminando sola por la playa con amigos europeos.
Y muchas veces,
cuando visitaba a mi abuela o amigos en edificios de gente de clase alta,
era invitada a no usar el ascensor principal.
Porque al final,
con este color y este pelo,
no puedo pertenecer a ciertos lugares.
De alguna manera, me acostumbré a ello y lo acepté un tanto.
Sin embargo, algo dentro de mí sigue rebelde y peleando.
Años después me casé con un español.
Pero no cualquier español.
Elegí uno con el color de piel de una langosta quemada por el sol.
(Risas)
Desde entonces, una nueva pregunta comenzó a perseguirme:
¿cuál será el color de nuestros hijos?
Como se pueden imaginar, esto es la menor de mis preocupaciones.
Pero pensando al respecto,
con mi experiencia pasada,
mi historia me llevó a hacer un experimento personal como fotógrafa.
Y así es como nació Humanae.
Humanae es un intento por resaltar nuestros verdaderos colores de piel,
en vez de los falsos:
el blanco, rojo, negro o amarillo asociados a la raza.
Es una especie de juego para poner en tela de juicio nuestros códigos.
Es un trabajo en curso de una historia personal a una historia universal.
Fotografío a los sujetos sobre un fondo blanco.
Luego elijo un cuadrado de 11 pixeles de la nariz,
pinto el fondo
y busco el color correspondiente en el catálogo industrial Pantone.
Comencé con mi familia y amigos,
luego más y más personas se unieron a esta aventura,
gracias a llamadas públicas hechas en las redes sociales.
Consideré que el espacio más adecuado para mostrar mi trabajo era Internet
porque quiero un concepto abierto
que invita a apretar el botón "compartir"
en todas las computadoras y cabezas.
La bola de nueve empezó a rodar.
El proyecto tuvo una gran acogida
e invitaciones, exposiciones,
presentaciones en soporte material,
galerías y museos
llegaron solos.
Y entre ellos, mi favorito:
cuando Humanae ocupa espacios públicos
y aparece en las calles,
fomenta el debate popular
y crea un espíritu de comunidad.
He retratado a más de 3000 personas
en 13 países diferentes,
en 19 ciudades diferentes alrededor del mundo.
Solo para mencionar algunos de ellos:
desde alguien incluido en la lista de Forbes,
a refugiados que cruzaron el Mediterráneo en barco;
en París, desde la sede de UNESCO a los hogares de acogida,
y también estudiantes, tanto de Suiza como de las favelas de Río de Janeiro.
Cada con su creencia,
identidad de género
o deficiencia física;
desde un recién nacido a un enfermo terminal.
Todos juntos formamos Humanae.
Esos retratos nos obligan replantear el cómo nos vemos unos a otros.
Mientras la ciencia moderna está cuestionando el concepto de raza,
¿qué significa para nosotros ser negro, blanco, amarillo o rojo?
¿Son los ojos, la nariz, la boca, el pelo?
¿O tiene que ver con nuestro origen,
nacionalidad o cuenta bancaria?
Este ejercicio personal resultó ser un descubrimiento.
De repente me di cuenta de que Humanae era útil para muchas personas.
Representa una especie de espejo
para aquellos que no se ven reflejados en ninguna etiqueta.
Fue increíble
que la gente empezó a compartir conmigo lo que pensaba de mi trabajo.
Recibo cientos de opiniones,
compartiré unas cuantas también.
La madre de una niña de 11 años me escribió:
"Es una herramienta excelente para trabajar con su confianza,
ya que el fin de semana pasado una de sus amigas discutió con ella
y le dijo que esto no es su lugar
y que no debería serle permitido vivir en Noruega.
Así que su trabajo tiene un lugar muy especial en mi corazón
y es muy importante para mí".
Una mujer compartió su retrato en Facebook y escribió,
"Toda mi vida,
todo el mundo ha tenido dificultades para ubicarme en un grupo,
un estereotipo, una caja.
Quizás deberíamos parar.
En vez de encasillar, pregunta a la persona:
'¿Cómo te describirías tu mismo?'
Entonces yo diría,
'Hola. Soy Massiel.
Soy dominicano-holandesa,
crecí en una familia mixta
y soy una mujer bisexual'".
Más allá de las reacciones emotivas e inesperadas,
Humanae encuentra una nuevo reto en muchos otros campos diferentes.
Para dar algunos ejemplos,
ilustradores y estudiantes de arte
lo utilizan como una referencia para sus dibujos y sus estudios.
Es una colección de caras.
Investigadores en el campo de la antropología,
la física y las neurociencias,
utilizan Humanae con distintos enfoques científicos
relacionados a la etnología humana, la optofisiología;
el reconocimiento facial o el Alzheimer.
Una de las consecuencias más importantes del proyecto
es que Humanae fue elegido para ser la portada de Foreign Affairs,
uno de las publicaciones políticas más relevantes.
Y hablando de asuntos exteriores,
he encontrado los embajadores perfectos para mi proyecto:
los maestros.
Ellos son los que utilizan Humanae como una herramienta educativa.
Su pasión me anima retomar la clase de dibujo,
pero esta vez como profesora.
Mis alumnos,
tanto adultos como niños,
pintan sus autorretratos
tratando de descubrir su color propio y único.
Como fotógrafa,
me doy cuenta de que puedo ser un canal para que otros se comuniquen.
Como individuo,
como Angélica,
cada vez que tomo una fotografía,
siento que estoy sentada delante de un terapeuta.
Toda la frustración, el miedo y la soledad que una vez sentí,
se convierten en amor.
El último país --
el último país del mundo en abolir la esclavitud
es el país donde nací:
Brasil.
Todavía tenemos que trabajar duro para abolir la discriminación
que sigue siendo común en todo el mundo,
y que no va a desaparecer por sí sola.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)